Hello.
Thanks for the introduction,
and welcome to the talk
on the application
of a knowledge
graph to enhance
price analytics in
the procurement
domain. Before we
look at the agenda,
let me introduce myself.
My name is Markus Noelke.
I work for Siemens Energy,
now for more than ten years.
My office is located
at the factory
in Mulheim close
to Dusseldorf.
As a cost value engineer,
I act as a bridge
between engineering,
procurement, suppliers,
with focus on improving our
product cost position.
For cost transparency and
identification of
cost out potential,
I utilize extensively
data analytics.
In the presentation,
I will explain the use case or
motivation for the application
of an application,
with details on
used ontologies,
patterns, and tools.
Presentation is
structured as follows.
I will give a short overview
about Siemens Energy and then
explain what I
mean by advanced
price analytics and
will show you,
the related knowledge graph
implementation.
And I will close
out with a short
summary and and
next steps.
But let us first,
start with the introduction of
Siemens Energy.
Siemens Energy is active in
the energy market,
mainly as an equipment
supplier,
with a global footprint.
More than fifty percent
on the worldwide
installed generation capacity
is based on our technology.
Although we have
a fossil background,
we are transforming
to renewables,
and our our
portfolio is already
more than fifty
percent carbon free.
Along our core products,
we offer solutions and and
services mainly
maintenance and repair.
We have products
in generation,
transmission, and
storage of energy.
The portfolio ranges from
conventional
equipment like gas
turbines, to renewables,
like wind turbines,
through our daughter,
we, Garmesa,
Siemens Garmesa,
and to hydrogen generators.
The use case currently focuses
on conventional gas turbines.
So let us have a look
at the product
structure and, the, related,
supply chain.
Our product portfolio
is, quite large,
including systems,
with subsystems or
sub subsystems.
So here on the left,
you can see,
there's a complete gas fired
power plant, which we sell.
And then what we also sell is
the just the gas
turbine package,
which is within
this power plant.
And the gas turbine
package can
be further broken down into
the core engine,
the gas turbine,
the actual gas
turbine which we
manufacture in house,
and also auxiliary
elements like
the air intake which provides
filter air to
the filter air to
the to the gas turbine.
So this, we buy,
complete as a as a system,
but as mentioned,
the gas turbine,
that is manufactured
in house.
So here, we need to
further break down,
into components,
which are quite numerous.
So from machine parts
to raw material,
standard parts like bolts and
nuts and and and and so on.
And and so we we buy all sorts
of things from
systems all the way
down to to raw material
and also seems,
energy buys a lot at about ten
billion euros annually.
It's the purchase volume.
Almost all components,
are engineered with,
lot size one.
They vary from
project to project
most often.
And, yeah,
the specification are always
need need to always
to be adapted.
We have a global
purchasing footprint,
with regional
hubs, and, like,
with global supply
base, of course,
following our projects and and
customers. And we
have, lastly,
facing strong competition and
our our cost base is
heavily influenced,
of course, by
the external supply,
and we have to to
buy at best price.
And there we have
finally our use case.
We use data
analytics to detail
to to determine if we actually
buy always throughout
the entire
organization at best
price possible.
And one example or one method
here is the, perform what we
call the performance pricing.
That means relating,
the price of
a purchased item,
to its aspects
and properties.
So here is one example
of a dashboard
with an air intake portfolio,
where prices for
air intakes are
shown globally
for our entire,
gas turbine,
portfolio from from
small gas turbines,
with low mass
flow to large gas
turbines with
a large mass flow,
and we have all
the cost information,
mapped here in this chart over
the mass flow.
And and we have,
one one type of
of data is from
from our estimated from our
product tracking databases,
for instance, from proposal
calculation and so on.
And the other
prices are actually
projection prices from from
purchase orders
which are fixed,
and this can also
be shown here.
And, with this method,
you can compare
price over a wide
range of application
with varying
parameters. The results might
be a benchmark
prices so you can
determine an average
price line
here for instance
over the the entire
portfolio, or you can even
determine a lowest
price line,
or you can investigate further
outliers here, and and and do
further drill down.
So, also,
you can derive
target cost here
if you want. So if you design
a new gas turbine and you just
know the functional
parameter,
mass flow, you can go in here
and determine a price for this
component which
is not actually
designed at this
point in time.
So that is, as you can see,
that is a very simple method
with just one parameter but in
reality we have
of course several
parameters, which are crucial
for for for for
influencing the price,
which we call
the cost driver,
and and they need
to be evaluated
in a multivariate regression.
But also, you can
see that this
easy statistical method also
relies on the collection and
integration of lots of data
throughout the whole supply
chain organization,
but also integrating a lot of
technical information.
And that is the problem we try
to solve with
the knowledge graph.
But there are some
challenges as,
yep, as probably in
many organizations.
We have,
unstructured data like pricing
information comes
to PDF technical
documentation. We
have Excel sheets.
We have drawings.
Some information
comes, per email.
Also, as shown, we
have high complexity,
of products.
So the it's
quite heterogeneous
what we buy.
We have also procurement and
also engineering
and manufacturing
is distributed globally.
We have that really
results also
in different philosophies,
legacy systems,
and and related vocabulary.
And, of course,
we have data more organized in
applications, and if data is
pulled out of its relational
databases mostly
the context is gone.
So, the general
idea here is to
use a good knowledge graph,
to integrate, the data and,
defining a shared vocabulary
across all the domains,
procurement,
engineering,
technical vocabulary,
but also service,
for instance,
and manufacturing.
And there, the idea is to,
to have a data integration cut
from within based
on on the knowledge
graph, and then
we bring together
all the transactional data,
planning data,
design data from
various data silos,
and, we map them,
to the individual
concepts classes,
and and and shared
the vocabulary,
and and we can evaluate it.
And in that process,
information becomes knowledge
that can be formally processed
by a machine. So here,
this is one example.
Firefront is assigned a unit,
which is defined in the core
ontology of the QEDT.
Then we have,
okay we say it's
an inlet mass flow,
it's a value for an inlet mass
flow which is defined
in the domain
ontology that can
also be defined
by international standards.
And then,
this inlet mass flow is mapped
to to technical asset,
the air intake,
which has also a corresponding
semantic definition.
It's it's a technical asset,
which again is defined in in
the core ontology.
And then, yeah,
this this data with
a shared vocabulary,
this map data can
then be shared
to applications
through an API,
and the apps can query content
from the notice
graph via sparkle
queries. And and here we have
also on the top our
performance pricing,
dashboards, but also, yeah,
just simple query
visualizations,
traversing the graph,
doing graph,
explorations is
also possible.
But let's look further
at the ontology
framework, we are using here.
So modeling scope,
respectively,
technical assets is is done
along with the ISO
and the asset
specification model
from the REDI
project. So here,
the gas turbine,
in this example,
the gas turbine
auxiliary system
is modeled, with a system
engineering
approach starting,
with the main system and,
breaking it further
down into,
subcomponents, all the way to
the bottom here.
So that is that generally is
done related to aspects,
to the aspects
function, product,
and location as per the ISO,
eight one three four six.
The product aspect
is here omitted
for the sake of, simplicity.
So function and
location are here,
part of quite
quite a different
breakdown of hierarchies.
And and, by mixing
the two aspects,
variable context contextual,
information is is is lost.
And and here also location can
be referred to,
boundary conditions,
where you apply your
technical assets.
Along with the aspects,
functional properties,
we we which are modeled here,
which is the the power,
for instance,
requirement for the guest,
auxiliary system,
and also the mass flow.
We can also,
model location
related properties,
which wind which
is wind speed,
temperature,
which is different
indoor than,
compared to outdoor.
And, so and and
then, the the,
and an integrated
object is created,
through connecting,
the respective objects in in
the hierarchies,
and that is basically
the specification
for for this, intake.
And, it's it's
a functional object,
and it integrates
all the aspects
and and,
and all the requirements are
then flowing down,
to this functional object.
And, then this objects can be
also related to
to offers being
made for such an asset,
or purchased,
orders being placed.
And this gives the connection
between the cost data,
and the technical parameters,
which can then be utilized,
in the performance,
pricing effort.
But be before we get to that,
I show you how to,
to model the,
the properties.
So what what are the typical
property patterns here?
Here we have,
the the ISO one five nine two
six fourteen pattern
with a verification
, which has a higher,
expressivity,
than modeling
properties directly,
to the assets.
So, yeah, here we have,
the the the type,
of of of the property as a as
a as an instance
of of a class,
where the class is,
this is the nominal
operating mass flow,
which is defined by
a g force standard.
And it can also, classify,
the functional object
further into,
an oil and gas type
of equipment.
And then to this,
mass flow instance,
we have the actual value,
connected and also,
the, the unit,
which is coming
from QEDT or is
mapped to the QEDT framework.
For the purchase order,
the quotation here,
we have to map,
for instance,
a monetary value,
which is,
a class from defined
in in the Fibo
ontology. And and
there, we have,
also, yeah, the value,
then the verification,
with the value connected and
also the currency connected.
And and the currency,
is defined also
through the Fibro
ontology where you have all
the currencies and
all the country
codes, mapped,
and and defined
in the ontology.
So yeah. And and
that brings us
then to the, yeah,
to the integration
and into our
use case.
And, here's the example,
we we looked at already.
And here you can see how how
everything comes together.
So we have here now,
the our functional
object, basically,
with the connected
estimated as pricing,
for instance,
from a quotation.
And we have the properties
basically here
from from this,
asset specification model.
So in this case,
the mass flow,
which are then maps,
so we we have this
connection here,
and we have also
the connection
here of to the purchase
part, which is,
coming from a purchase order
transaction for a different,
functional object,
and and that gives
us the possibility,
to, derive that, dashboard,
in an automatic way,
for all sorts of
technical assets
which are defined
in the knowledge
graph and all,
defines, technical,
or properties or qualities we
have in the knowledge graph or
which can be fine,
and and then we can do our
analytics based on that.
But, to make that all work,
we need reasoning.
Here, it's based on on all,
or additional data log rules,
based on
the RDFox implementation
we have here in in
various areas.
So one one example
here is the,
the property allocation from
the partonomies.
So if you're on top,
we have defined,
power requirement.
It is,
then serving down to
the subcomponents,
basically. Also,
the part of is is also
it's a transitive
property, so you
have also that
that connection.
But for instance,
if the filtration is also part
of the GG auxiliary
system that
is then a separate property,
so do not not mix direct part
relationship to to to indirect
part relationships.
Then we have
the aggregation of cost.
So if you have,
a percolation scheme where we
have to add, yeah,
certain components,
and and and aggregate it into
into a higher scope,
for instance,
for mechanical
equipment for a certain
project. That is
also done through
reasoning, and we
have the integration
of the data with
identifier matching.
So here,
ISO eight one
three four six IDs
can be used, or also,
legacy identifiers
from the various
databases to bring,
the data together.
And then finally, we have,
constraint checking here with
subclass requirements
to check if,
certain technical assets,
where we have the, yeah,
requirements for for certain
technical values if they are
present and also
if they are in
a certain range.
And and and here, yeah,
we need to rely also on closed
word reasoning,
which is also coming
from the RDFox
database technology.
And that leads me
to the architecture
which is implemented.
So this is the software
architecture,
starting from the from
the data sources.
So here we have
a center query,
point, via Denodo.
Through an ODBC connection,
we can access, for
instance, SAP data,
or other databases.
We have connected
Oracle database,
Redshift data warehouse,
and or a simple Excel sheets.
And then, yeah,
we can, via SQL,
we can get the tabular data.
And in in in the SQL lens,
this data is then using the r
two r m l mapping
files or mapping
language, is then transferred
into r d f RDF,
so called n quotes
which contain
also as a fourth
dimension the provenance
data, that is put into
the TRIPISSTORM,
yeah, which contains
all the provenance
data and all historical data.
And then, yeah,
through either
direct replication
or special queries we have
connected our RDFox
reasoning engine,
which is, yeah
executing in memory,
inferencing and
reasoning based
on data log rules
or old ontologies.
And, yeah.
And that is the the databases
are queried through,
the Metafactory front
end, which is,
a low code, yeah,
tool to enable traversing,
through the graph
and visualizing
graph data, within
HTML pages,
and so that the spaCy queries
can be directly
incorporated in
HTML pages.
And also there are
web connectors
defined for a dashboard tool
like Tableau,
where you can directly then,
from Tableau,
query into through Metafactory
query into the data
in the graph
database, which
is not directly
possible from Tableau.
And also, yeah, you can,
through Metafactory, factory,
you can realize certain class
based visualizations or just
simple graph
exploration schemes.
And, of course,
that is then
connected to a user
management system.
Alright. That's all.
So I would like to conclude
the talk with
conclusion and and
also some next steps.
So I think the, the,
knowledge graph is
a good solution
for for applying performance
pricing at scale.
It really reduces,
the manual work we have to do
right now to collect
all the data
to clean,
and and and to to put it into
a spreadsheet so we
can analyze it.
So with this approach,
an automatic or semiautomatic
performance pricing throughout
all components
we are buying is
possible. But, also,
what is what is,
yeah, I think, clear is that
the supply chain
is in a difficult
domain to model because we we
are more inter
interface, discipline.
So we rely on on
on good data,
and the right data
models from from,
engineering, from the product
life cycle management.
And, yeah, then so
so we, we and and,
also, they they said
the the models,
are quite heterogeneous,
and that makes life difficult
in in the knowledge graph.
And, also, I think,
closed word reasoning
is is essential,
to get, yeah,
the reasoning we we need,
to to make connections and and
to to do the constraint
checking here.
And, yeah, possible
next steps,
I would say, from
my perspective,
is really adding, equations.
So once we have
the statistical
analytics in place and we have
to derive, for instance,
a parametric formula
for an intake,
I would like to put that into
the graph and
also do reasoning
against that.
So if if, let's say,
identifying outliers based on
that and and
utilizing the numeric
calculation also for further,
analytics. And,
also, of course,
it would be very nice to link
external data, like
a material index.
So for instance, if you have,
so you can map, for instance,
for all technical assets which
use in certain carbon steel.
You can map easily,
the price index and have,
direct information
flowing into,
what are the price,
what is the price increase for
this particular raw material.
Also very important for for
certain for tracking, price,
for for tracking,
price movements in
the in the market.
Yeah. And lastly,
I think also it's it's a good
possibility to to do,
data exchange with
your business
partners, with
your suppliers,
but also with your customers.
So with suppliers,
I could imagine that
at the end that,
proposals, are
really exchanged
through the knowledge graph,
and we don't get PDFs,
which we have to,
then evaluate further.
So and extract
the valuable information,
but, yeah, so we can
get, already the,
the semantic
enriched information
from a supplier.
And, also, we have already
projects with customers where
they are asking for a certain
data model, for
instance, in Geforce,
which needs to be modeled in,
in an old graph. Yeah.
So that's concluding
my talk, and,
yeah, I'm happy to answer
additional questions.
Thanks a lot.